It's 1999 Russia had just come out of a
bloody war with the region south of
Russia next to Georgia called chechnya
after the collapse of the Soviet Union
chechnya declared independence that
didn't set well with Russia so just like
with the war in Ukraine today Russia
tried to bring the country back under
its control by force the only problem
was there were Chechen rebels in Russia
for years these Rebels would carry out
attacks against Russians on their home
turf chachan Fighters had infiltrated
the country they lived like Russians
waiting for the chance to attack
something had to be done the Russian
president Boris Yeltsin had ensured the
population that there was going to be
peace but that wasn't enough the
Patriotic people of Mother Russia wanted
a strong leader someone who could unite
the country take on chechnya and prove
Russia's strength and in the background
a little-known man was hatching a plan
to take advantage of this crisis and
seize power a man by the name of
Vladimir Putin September 4th 1999 a
massive explosion rocks a Barracks
housing Russian soldiers and their
families 64 people men women children
are pulled out of the rubble dead the
suspects according to the Russian
government it was Chechen terrorists
September 13th nine days later everyone
is on edge since the last bombing and
residents of an apartment building in
Moscow noticed some suspicious activity
in the building's Lobby and reported to
police the police searched the building
and found nothing they leave around 2 AM
by 503 am a bond in the basement rips
the building aparts
121 people die in their sleep who was
responsible the chechens of course
within just 12 Days a total of four
bombs would explode killing 300 Russian
citizens and spreading Panic throughout
the country after the first Chechen War
most Russians hated or at least disliked
chechens now with four Chechen attacks
in just 12 days they were seeing red and
they wanted to see some payback that is
where Putin came in see at the time
Vladimir Putin was was the Prime
Minister of Russia which is basically
the second in command after the actual
presidents and compared to today barely
anyone knew who he was he was a nobody
in the eyes of the public but he made
sure that that was about to change
within days Russia launched a full-scale
Invasion against the Chechen Capital
spearheaded by Putin Putin was Russia's
Avenger and in an instant he became a
national hero conveniently he was
running for president at the time in
August 1999 Vladimir Putin had only two
percent of the country's support for
presidents after the bombings president
Boris Johnson suddenly steps down and by
March 2000 Putin seizes the presidential
office with 53 percent of the votes
Putin had given the Russian people what
they wanted revenge and a strong leader
there was only one problem there were
some inconsistencies with the four
bombings most people believed the
government's story but a small group of
Skeptics discovered some holes in the
narrative they could never have imagined
where those questions would lead them
you see aside from the four bombs there
was actually a fifth bomb planted in
another apartment building except this
one didn't go off the residents saw two
men carrying large bags into the
building's basement before speeding away
so thankfully they called the police
immediately turns out the bags were
actually three 110 pound bombs wired to
a Detonator and timer an FSB explosives
expert was called in and he confirmed
the suspicions the bass contained a
powerful explosive known as RDX and if
it went off it would bring the entire
building down by the afternoon the news
has spread throughout Russia prime
minister poon congratulated the
residents further courage and vigilance
but here's where things get interesting
you see because the residents had called
the cops so quickly they were actually
able to catch the two men who planted
the explosives in the building the two
men carried sfb IDs the sfb is basically
the equivalent of America's FBI soon
after they were caught a call from sfb
headquarters came through ordering the
police to release them the next morning
the entire narrative changed the bags
never had any explosives in them just
white sugar and the two men they were
apparently part of a training exercise
for the FSB
something was seriously off had the FSB
really sacrificed 300 innocent Russians
to get Putin into Power that's what many
journalists try to find out one of them
was Alexander liftedenka and Alexander
was later found dead poisoned by the
Russian governments even though most
people don't want to talk about it it's
an unspoken reality Vladimir Putin and
his friends at the FSB had most likely
arranged those bombings to get Putin
into power under Vladimir Putin Russia
was changed forever and the FSB it
became one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire country
this is the FSB Putin's eyes and ears
his army of operatives that serve at his
beck and call and was some referred to
as Russia's Shadow governments
at the end of the Cold War Russia was
down on his luck politically
economically and financially
unfortunately Russia couldn't just apply
for a loan or take out a credit card to
help improve the economy and sometimes
it can be like that for people too you
can't get a loan because your credit
isn't strong enough and you can't build
up your credit because you need a credit
card to build up your credit but to get
a credit card you need good credit but
to have good credit you need a credit
card do you see what I'm getting at here
this Catch-22 didn't seem fair to a
group of smart people so they created
extra extra is the world's first ever
debit card that lets you build your
credit yes that is right a debit card
that builds your credit it even lets you
earn reward points just like a real
credit card but without the credit
check's interests and the risk of owing
money to your bank here's how it works
you head to the link below you sign up
and link your bank account once you've
signed up you'll get your extra card in
the mail and whenever you want to buy
something just swipe your extra card
just like you would with any other card
and extra will spot your purchase extra
would then auto pay themselves back the
next business day and at the end of the
month all of those purchases are
reported back to the credit bureaus as
credit worthy purchases building your
credit and you get all of this without
having to make a deposit or go through a
credit check so if you want to start
billing your credit today pause the
video and go to extra.app Jake trim with
the link below that's extra.app.j Trend
with the link below thanks to Astro for
sponsoring this video
thank you
Russia has three main intelligence
agencies the gru Russia's Military
Intelligence the svr which is Russia's
foreign intelligence and the equivalent
of the CIA and the FSB which works like
America's FBI except they get the color
Outside the Lines a lot more the FSB was
officially created on April 1995. they
mostly worked inside Russia but although
over the years Putin has given them more
and more power to operate
internationally it's no surprise that
the FSB is Putin's favorite intelligence
agency they're partly responsible for
him becoming president after all but
that's not the only reason why they're
his puppets you see unlike the Gru and
the svr the FSB has become an expert in
Putin talk they tell Putin what he wants
to hear when Putin wants to do something
crazy and dangerous they're the ones who
volunteer while everyone else is doing
risk analysis and because there are so
many different agencies in Russia vying
for Putin's favor him picking the FSB as
his baby has made for some stiff
competition which means that FSB has
taken even more risk to maintain Putin's
favor
a liberal politician and Vladimir
Putin's biggest opposition before Putin
became president everyone expected
nimsoft to win the throne after Putin
won nimsoft took every opportunity he
got to take on the presidents he was
playing a dangerous game
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
never imagined what the government would
do to him in return he was a public
figure people would know who was
responsible if something were to happen
to him Putin might hate him but he
wouldn't do anything rash would he
unfortunately Boris nymphsoff had
forgotten about the FSB
February 27 2015 Boris nimsoft was in
Moscow to lead a protest against the
first invasion of Ukraine
little did he know that he was being
followed and this wasn't even a recent
thing it turned out that FSB agents have
been telling him for over a year the
agent responsible for following nimsa's
every move Valerie sugarev the agent
used an FSB tracking software to see
exactly where and when nimsoft bought
tickets for any sort of public
transportation when nimsoft booked a
trip Valerie would be sure to arrive at
the same location at the same time in
dates Valerie have followed nimsoft to
Moscow for the protest he had people
following nimsoft all the way to right
outside the Kremlin as he walked with a
friend and that's when it happened at 11
31 PM immense that out of the shadows
and fires six shots in the nimsa's chest
he died immediately
coincidentally most of the cameras on
the bridge where he was shot were turned
off for maintenance unlike other Russian
intelligence agencies the FSB doesn't
need to move in the shadows if they want
to get rid of someone they don't need to
make it look like an accident they don't
even need to hide their faces because
they're on their home turf why hide your
face if you can just turn off the CCTV
cameras and even if they're identified
who's gonna arrest them the FSB in
Russia FSB agents are all powerful for
years they were it contained threats
they only operated in Russia but today
the agency has expanded its operations
internationally and ever since the world
has gone a whole lot more dangerous
foreign
just because the FSB doesn't need to
hide their assassinations doesn't mean
they don't like to get a little creative
every now and then remember Valerie
sukarev the agent who followed Wars
nymphsoff well he was actually involved
in two other assassination attempts
before nimsov every time the target was
one of the Queen's opponents Alexi
navani was one of these critics and he
announced his plan to run for president
in 2017. almost immediately an FSB team
was assigned to watch him for three
years they followed him pretty much
everywhere including more than 30
flights in August 2020 three men fall in
the volley to the Russian city of tomsk
their objective get rid of navalny on
orders from quote the highest echelons
of the Kremlin End quotes
the agents chose novichoke an insanely
powerful poison as their weapon of
choice luckily navalny survived after
being evacuated to Germany and then
there was the poisoning of Ukrainian
presidents Victor yuschenko FSB agents
laced his soup with dioxin a poisonous
chemical in agent orange the same
Ancient Orange America used in the
Vietnam War and if you think the FSB has
calmed down over time just this year
they were suspected of poisoning Russian
oligarch and ex-chelsea football club
owner Roman Abramovich after Russia
invaded Ukraine Roman volunteered as a
peacemaker without Putin's permission
apparently the Kremlin wasn't very happy
with his decision in March 2022 he and
the two ukrainians he met in Kiev
suddenly became sick lost their sights
and had to be evacuated to Turkey for
treatments the cause poisoning most
likely by FSB agents now that the FSB is
operating internationally I'm sure
Putin's critics are going to be a lot
more careful with their soup and tea
foreign
[Music]
Ty runs a program called sorm2 which
basically tracks and Records everyone's
messages calls internet posts and
searches in Russia that's how they
identify activists and Putin's
opposition that's how they track their
every move before the FSB could only do
that with Russian websites and social
media but now even Facebook and Google
have to install it this lets the FSB
leak embarrassing calls Boris nimsoft
made to the public and a lesson the
Volney a court case against him also
used information that could only be
collected by sorm the officers of the
FSB have unlimited access to everything
someone has online or in their phone
this has allowed them to become the most
powerful government agency in Russia
the fsb's position as Russia's secret
police has given them unrivaled power
they have the authority to take action
against anyone they see as a threat
against Russia and that doesn't just
include terrorists but politicians
businessmen activists anyone is fair
game to the FSB and today the FSB has
taken control of many of the biggest
government branches including the
ministry of Defense the interior
Ministry the general prosecutor's office
and more FSB agents can even control
judges and use worse tactics than the
KGB could have ever imagined when Putin
wants something that FSB provides the
rationale when Putin wanted an excuse to
invade Ukraine this year the head at the
FSB was there to give his supports the
combination of a dictator president and
an all-powerful intelligence agency with
the power to do whatever they want can
only spell trouble for the rest of the
world
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the
video and if you're new here my name is
Jake and we make documentaries on money
power and crime just like this one for
free for your viewing pleasure so you
might as well hit that subscribe button
and that join button if you want even
more controversial documentaries every
single month that are even longer you
can follow me on Instagram jtrend.io
please watch out for fake Instagram
accounts of me I'm never gonna DM you on
Instagram asking for money and that's
pretty much it thanks for watching stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
thank you
thank you